I'm going to break down this Crosser
extension that I like to do that a lot
of people ask about that looks really
neat flows really nicely and isn't
actually that difficult prerequisites
are knowing how to do split Time same
direction crossers from these crossers
you're going to pick a hand so I'm going
to pick my blue po here which is kind of
above my my
shoulder and as it comes out from
behind that shoulder I'm going to extend
it around and then put it back behind my
shoulder so you want to get used to
doing that a few times which is kind of
a fun flourish in and up
itself once you get used to that side
take the other side now my orange POI
which is kind of under my armpit as it
comes out from behind my shoulder under
my armpit I'm going to extend it around
as well so I'm dropping it out of my
armpit around and then tucking it back
[Music]
in once you get both parts you want to
try to combine the
two which looks like
this you'll notice there's this nice
sort of sliding along the arms and so
let's break that down so to practice the
arm position get your arms into the same
position that you were for a Crosser but
let's put the hand on top out like this
now what you're going to do is you're
going to swing this hand down sliding
along it with your other hand until
you've got a cross down here now slide
what used to be the extended hand up to
the shoulder on the other side from here
you're going to slide up until you've
got a cross up over your head and slide
this hand down into your
armpit notice how my my hands are never
uncrossing they're never twisting or
weaving or anything like that around
each
other I'm just sliding them in and out
as I rock my body in a cross position
so with
po there's one side there's the other
side there's both
sides uhoh that was the microphone you
fix
that hey if anybody wants a taxi to go
to dinner come meet us over here cuz
we're doing that right now this part
will be
cut all right we're back this time we
aren't going to slide which means means
we won't be extending and Contracting
we're going to be extending and then
doing a bit of a flower pedal or like a
momentary
isolation basically the same move but
more isolated more like a hybrid and
then if you really want to get crazy you
can always switch which way one is
spinning that's too trippy
want yay